on parle de la Coupe du Monde on parle
de chanter devant des centaines des
milliards qu'on venait de le dire donc
on est dans un cas particulier on est
dans un cadeau ça ne se refuse pas c'est
je suis chanteur il y a des grands
artistes qui ont refusé hein
grands méga méga artistes qui ont
accepté donc c'est quelque chose qui a
été décidé dans un cadre spécial il y a
quelques années pendant le confinement
j'ai dit oui aujourd'hui on a les
polémiques on a tout ce qui se dit
autour du Qatar des choses qui sont
certainement vrai des choses qui
concernent les droits de l'homme des qui
concerne plein de choses bien sûr on a
l'impression que j'ai accepté le truc
avant-hier ça serait arrivé il y a une
semaine le cadre aurait été totalement
différent mais c'est pas le cas
voilà en tout cas il assume maître Gims
voilà il chantera lors de la finale le
18 décembre il est le seul artiste
français invité à participer au chaud il
y aura Shakira Dua Lipa Rod Stewart non
ils ont refusé
et il y aura apparemment
on parle on est la taupe non non il y
aura des grands artistes à qui alors
finalement il y aura qui personne y aura
gimsuna il y aura plein d'artistes
internationaux il y avait le chanteur du
groupe BTS aussi qui va revenir et moi
il me saoule la c'est journaliste bien
pensant à faire la morale aux artistes
alors que c'est les premiers à regarder
les les matchs chez eux c'est toi qui
sont c'est pas pourquoi c'est moi qui
saoule c'est pas parce que tu regardes
une c'est pas parce que tu chantes à une
compétition que tu cautionnes toute
l'histoire c'est tout le temps ça c'est
pas parce qu'on fait les choses donc il
faudrait rien faire avec ceux qui
refusent de se produire sont
insupportables parce qu'ils font passer
ceux qui disent oui pour des vendus
alors qu'ils veulent juste exercer leur
métier Gims
c'est pas parce que je vais couper l'eau
que tout d'un coup l'écologie ira mieux
bah si c'est parce que chacun fait tous
les jours personne ne fait rien
n'importe quoi écoute-moi il va chanter
dans un pays aujourd'hui on sait que ce
pays c'est et ne respecte pas les droits
de l'homme ne respecte pas
l'homosexualité ne respecte pas le
climat à tuer cette mille personnes
pour la Coupe du Monde
c'est exactement ce qu'il fait il aurait
tout mon respect s'il dit ok j'y vais et
l'argent que je prends je le reverser
une Asos merci de l'argent honte à lui
honte à lui
bien sûr il a dit je sais pas attends
peut-être qu'il va le dire après il
représente moi je suis fier de maître
Gims de GIPS il représente la France
mais bien sûr il va exprimer son arrêt
de la vie lui-même devant des milliards
de gens qui vont regarder ça on va
l'entendre chanter mais bravo charisme
d'un drapeau dans le vent mec c'est
quand même fascinant tu changes d'avis
et j'arrive dans un drapeau dans le vent
oui le monter comme ça celle-là adieu je
la valide
tu as le charisme drapeau dans le ventre
les droits de l'homme les gens qui n'ont
rien à voir hein je n'ai jamais changé
d'avis sur la Coupe du Monde au Canada
c'est bien droit autour du change de
dise c'est bien là donc changer de
chanter dans un pays peu importe le foot
il va chanter dans un pays qui avait
homophobe et qui ne respecte pas les
droits de l'homme il respecte pas le
climat qui a tué 7000 par semaine pour
créer quelque chose
moi je suis depuis le début je pense un
peu comme toi mais je pense que malgré
tout c'est 20 et hypocrites moi je
considère de manière très prétentieuse
que mes valeurs que c'est mieux d'être
une femme aujourd'hui en France coca-car
que c'est mieux d'être un homosexuel en
France cocata ça moi je peux le dire ici
en France tranquillement oui je trouve
qu'effectivement les homosexuels sont
maltraités au Qatar et je pense que ça
m'indigne mais mon hypocrisie mais mon
hypocrisie paradoxalement c'est que moi
je suis la première à aller au Parc des
Princes ça peut dire bah Pappé moi si je
vois ma paix je suis très content j'ai
demandé une photo et pourtant il joue
pour le Qatar c'est à dire que tu vois
en fait c'est pas si simple que ça et à
ce moment-là Darmanin qui va aller à la
demi-finale si jamais la France elle est
qualifiée alors que tu penses que est-ce
que est-ce que tu m'en voudrais
si j'allais voir la France jouer là-bas
honnêtement je pense que tu ferais une
erreur je t'en voudrais pas tu fais ce
que tu veux parce que si je t'invite tu
viendrais avec moi jamais de la vie tu
vois c'est vrai ah mais jamais j'irai
jamais au Qatar j'irai jamais je moi je
vous dis j'ai et là je peux appeler
pas totalement là je parle des femmes du
climat en Chine quand vous allez on
s'est [ __ ] de stade pour voir des gens
football il y a 7000 personnes qui sont
mortes en Chine
par exemple les palaces
si tu veux tout savoir j'allais à
l'hôtel je peux le citer ou pas c'était
l'hôtel
c'est peut-être le tien je sais pas
attends
tu peux
j'allais j'allais quand je touche un
petit peu d'argent j'allais c'était mon
petit plaisir une fois par mois faire un
son visage à l'hôtel Meurice rue de
Rivoli à Paris depuis que j'ai appris
qu'il était qu'il appartenait sous le
temps de du de chez puki qui
effectivement met les homosexuels en
prison les femmes tout ça voilà je n'y
ai plus jamais foutu les pieds alors
encore une fois alors qu'est-ce que je
dirais ce que dirait Guillaume ah bah ça
sert à rien c'est pas parce que tu
bouffes
hypocrites mais oui
c'est la Coupe du Monde c'est pas parce
que tu regardes un match que tu es
homophobe c'est pas parce que tu chantes
ce que tu es homophobe ou tu que tu veux
condamner je sais pas quelle cause non
phobie c'est les femmes c'est les droits
de femmes tous les pays
représentent à lui seul tout ce qu'il
faut plus faire dans le monde si je
tombe brouillais parce que tu as des
baskets qui sont fabriqués par des
petits enfants un peu plus rien faire
et je le dis je l'ai vu avec des baskets
donc
on va parler d'un autre sujet